[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute nichts
barbara hahlweg
guten abend schön dass sie dabei sind
wie auch norbert lehmann für den sport
ein stück unserer familie und das sind
die wichtigsten nachrichten themen von
heute
weniger russisches gas nach europa der
krieg behindert den gas transit durch
die ukraine die versorgung in
deutschland ist aktuell sicher
umstrittener dienstflug mit sohn
verteidigungsministerin lamprecht äußert
verständnis für die kritik betont aber
rechtlich sei alles korrekt gewesen
und können wir fürs elektroauto pro jahr
winken bis zu 400 euro
umweltverbände sehen den
zertifikatehandel kritisch
wegen des kriegs hat die ukraine
lieferung von russischem erdgas in
richtung westeuropa reduziert begründung
russlands besatzung mache die kontrolle
bestimmter anlagen unmöglich deutschland
kann den ausfall im moment offenbar
kompensieren die frage sei was noch
kommt sagt wirtschaftsminister habeck
über die lage im kriegsgebiet berichtet
lea sünner bruch kein gas mehr durch das
gebiet lugansk richtung westen die
ukraine dreht der gazprom pipeline syoss
den hahn zu hier flossen bisher täglich
mehr als 30 millionen kubikmeter gas
rund ein drittel der menge für europa
norwegen und die niederlande gleichen
das nun aus dem wirtschaftsministerium
heißt es dazu wir beobachten die lage
genau die versorgungssicherheit in
deutschland ist aktuell weiter
gewährleistet
es werde kriegsbedingt kein gas mehr
durch geleitet so der ukrainische
netzbetreiber und tatsächlich rückt
russland den regionen lohans und dann
jetzt weiter vor die ukraine spricht von
angriffen auf privathäuser und die
stromversorgung
einwohner eines dorfes beiden jetzt
zeigen ukrainischen minen räumen wo
nicht explodierte sprengsätze liegen
nach ukrainischen angaben gezielte
todesfallen die russen verwenden
sprengstoffe die explodieren können aber
man kann nicht feststellen wann sie
explodieren werden gefahr liegt darin
dass sie jederzeit explodieren und
jemanden verletzen oder töten
im nordosten des landes rund um die
großstadt kharkiv vermeldet hingegen die
ukraine geländegewinne diese bilder
sollen den beschuss eines russischen
panzers durch ukrainische truppen zeigen
der ukrainische präsident selensky
erklärt vor französischen studenten das
ziel der kämpfe vor allem wollen wir
unser land unser territorium wieder
herstellen bis russland uns das recht
hier zu leben zurück gibt und im moment
hat es nicht die absicht das zu tun dass
es das tut müssen wir für dieses recht
kämpfen
und das machen soldaten und einwohner
motiviert auch durch ihren präsidenten
um weiter stück für stück ihre dörfer
und städte zurückzuerobern
unsere reporterin katrin eigendorf ist
in charkiw in welchem zustand es die
stadt
wie man das hinter mir sehen kann das
hier ist ein typischer hinterhof mitten
in der innenstadt von raki von diesen
gibt es mehrere die so aussehen wo die
russische luftwaffe wirklich mitten in
wohnhäuser reingeschossen hat die
innenstadt hat hier viele viele
zerstörte gebäude
es ist immer noch gespenstisch still
heute abend wenn man hier durch die
stadt geht obwohl es inzwischen hier das
erste mal seit beginn des krieges zwei
tage gegeben hat in denen es nicht
permanente angriffe gegeben hat das hat
damit zu tun dass ist der ukrainischen
armee gelungen ist im norden und im
osten der stadt die russische armee
zurückzuschlagen zurückzudrängen das
heißt man geht davon aus dass beschuss
des zentrums also des direkten zehn
trupps von hps im moment nichts mehr
erwarten ist aber das ist natürlich
nicht sicher und die frontlinie bewegt
sich auch jeden tag also russen und
ukrainer stehen sich dagegen über und
die russen können durchaus auch wieder
vorrücken aber im moment so scheint es
ist die russische armee doch eher damit
beschäftigt in den don was zu gehen und
dort zu kämpfen
das gibt den menschen hier in haag ich
etwas luft aber wirklich entspannung
gibt es hier natürlich nicht katrin
eigendorf live aus st vielen dank für
diese einschätzung
um der ukraine militärisch zu helfen
wollen deutschland und die niederlande
insgesamt zwölf panzerhaubitzen 2000
liefern zudem haben sie zugesagt
ukrainische soldaten an den schweren
geschützen auszubilden in der bundeswehr
artillerieschule in idar oberstein hat
das training jetzt begonnen insgesamt
sollen dort bis zu 90 soldaten geschult
werden
eines der gefährlichsten einsatzgebiete
für bundeswehr soldaten und soldatinnen
ist mali in afrika
deutschland beteiligt sich dort an zwei
internationalen missionen heute
entschied das kabinett die eine die eu
ausbildungsmission wird zumindest in
mali beendet die andere die un
stabilisierungsmission soll aufgestockt
werden auf bis zu 1400
bundeswehr-soldaten susan von lojewski
berichtet sie trainieren regelmäßig für
den ernstfall soldatinnen und soldaten
der bundeswehr im malischen bei einem
übungs rettungseinsatz blut
es ist eine ihrer kernaufgaben bei der
un mission minustah
sie sollen das land stabilisieren und
helfen das friedensabkommen von 2015
umzusetzen doch von frieden ist molly so
weit weg wie lange nicht es ist nicht
besser geworden nicht wirklich das wäre
damit man etwas vormachen aber solange
wir hier sind und ein gewisses maß an
stabilität erzeugen können
wird der terror hier nicht die oberhand
gewinnen das camp der deutschen steht
mitten in der wüste marlies für die
un-truppen stellt die bundeswehr die
gesamte logistik strom wasser
unterbringung verpflegung zurzeit
leisten hier etwa 900 deutsche dienst
ihre stimmung schwankt zwischen diese
illusion ihr und hoffnung
ohne einen gewissen idealismus glaube
ich geht keiner einen auslandseinsatz
kein soldat man hat natürlich auch so
ein bisschen sein mal dieses
weltverbesserer tun vielleicht die
hoffnung dass man was bewirkt das größte
problem der bundeswehr wenn die
franzosen demnächst aus mali abziehen
ist der betrieb des wichtigen flughafens
gar nicht mehr sichergestellt die uno
muss also dringend einen ersatz für sie
finden sonst ist auch der einsatz der
bundeswehr schwierig bis unmöglich die
mission ist wesentlich von den deutschen
abhängig sie leisten mit ihren spät
drucks einen wichtigen beitrag zur
militärischen aufklärung diese einzige
leistungsfähige aufklärungs träger den
diese mission hat der würde wegfall und
keine andere nation stellt diese
fähigkeit bereit hier es ist ein
schmaler grat zwischen gehen oder
bleiben wie es für die bundeswehr in
mali weiter geht muss am ende der
bundestag entscheiden
die
verteidigungsministerin steht derzeit in
der kritik unter anderem weil sie ihren
sohn in einem regierungs hubschrauber
mitgenommen hat heute äußerte sich
christine lambrecht erstmals persönlich
dazu es sei rechtlich alles korrekt
gewesen ministrant
lamprecht junior in einem regierungs
helikopter das foto postete er auf
instagram diesen standort in
schleswig-holstein besuchte die
verteidigungsministerin ohne ihren sohn
doch auf den flug richtung
norddeutschland nahm sie ihn mit nach
dem truppenbesuch ging es für beide zum
osterurlaub nach sylt ich bin als
ministerin in der situation dass ich
sehr wenig zeit habe für privatleben und
insbesondere für den kontakt mit meinem
sohn und deswegen kann man diese
entscheidung in frage stellen dafür habe
ich auch verständnis ich bitte um
verständnis dafür dass es darum geht
eben auch den kontakt zum kind weiter
aufrecht zu halten der mitflug rechtlich
in ordnung regierungsmitglieder dürfen
familienangehörige auf dienstreisen
mitnehmen gibt es keinen dienstlichen
grund müssen die kosten erstattet werden
dennoch kritik aus opposition und aus
der koalition der flug vor dem
hintergrund des krieges instinktlos ich
kann nur so viel sagen es ist juristisch
offensichtlich möglich wenn keine
juristin nicht alles was juristisch
möglich ist ist unbedingt politisch
sinnstiftend hinzu kommt dass das
ministerium am montagvormittag einen
redakteur der welt gewarnt haben soll er
berichtet vor der offiziellen antwort am
montag erfolgte der inoffizielle hinweis
die volljuristin lamprecht behalte sich
rechtliche schritte gegen eine mögliche
berichterstattung vor also ich behalte
mir bei allen äußerungen die über mich
oder meine familie getroffen werden vor
entsprechend dann auch darauf zu
reagieren wenn es zur falschen
tatsachenbehauptungen konnte und ich
denke dass es auch im umgang der ist
akzeptabel aus dem ministerium heißt es
am abend lamprecht habe inzwischen
261 euro für den flug bezahlt kanzler
scholz sprang ihr zur seite alle
vorschriften seien beachtet wurden
am sonntag steht die wichtigste und wohl
spannendste landtagswahl des jahres an
im einwohner reichsten bundesland
nordrhein westfalen
die vergangenen fünf jahre hat dort
schwarz-gelb regiert erst
ministerpräsident laschet dann hendrik
wüst doch das könnte sich ändern die
grünen erwarten deutliche gewinne und
zwischen cdu und spd deutet sich ein
kopf an kopf rennen an um platz eins
dort bewerber stellt die beiden
spitzenkandidaten vor
machen worauf es ankommt hendrik wüst
slogan nordrhein westfalens
ministerpräsident kämpft um sein amt und
wirkt auf dem marktplatz von herford für
seine cdu themen
dafür auch in zukunft arbeitsplätze
sicher machen können in nordrhein
westfalen mit einer modernen wirtschaft
dass wir weiter für gute schulen sorgen
und für innere sicherheit
mal eben in den traktor klettern wüst
weiß sich in szene zu setzen seit sechs
monaten ist er im amt seither heißt das
ziel bekannt und beliebt werden als ich
das amt des ministerpräsidenten
übernommen habe hat meine partei 13
prozentpunkte hinter der spd gelegen
heute legen wir in den aktuellen
umfragen mindestens 2 prozent vorne also
die richtung stimmt jetzt noch der
rückenwind aus schleswig holstein
ich bin guter dinge spd herausforderer
thomas kutschaty ist auch guter dinge
sein der sozialdemokraten liefern sich
seit monaten in umfragen ein kopf an
kopf rennen mit der cdu die themen
bildung wohnen arbeit gute stimmung im
wahlkampf sehen die chancen stehen nicht
gut dass wir einen echten
regierungswechsel hier in nordrhein
westfalen hinbekommt in bonn bekommt
kutschaty unterstützung von saarlands
ministerpräsidentin anke rehlinger die
spd sieht so die botschaft die
niederlage von kiel schreckt nicht kiel
ist nicht köln und wüste ist nicht
günther das sind die entscheidenden
unterschiede zwischen schleswig holstein
und nordrhein westfalen hier nordrhein
westfalen wollen die menschen einen
wechsel die unzufriedenheit mit der
landesregierung ist hier groß cdu mit
hendrik wüst oder spd mit thomas
kutschaty in düsseldorf wird es sonntag
spannend
mehr über die landtagswahl in nordrhein
westfalen haben wir online und in der
zdf- heute- äpfel sie zusammengestellt
dort finden sie unter anderem
ausführliche interviews mit den
spitzenkandidaten aller parteien
nach der wahl in schleswig-holstein will
ministerpräsident günther die jamaika
koalition mit grünen und fdp fortsetzen
obwohl er eigentlich nur noch einen
partner bräuchte das hat er vor wenigen
minuten dem kleinen parteitag der cdu
vorgeschlagen jamaika sei die
wunschkoalition der bevölkerung am
dienstag sollen die gespräche mit grünen
und fdp beginnen
wer ein e auto fährt schont das klima
und kann sich dafür sogar belohnen
lassen denn seit diesem jahr winkt eine
zusätzliche prämie bis zu 400 euro im
jahr weil die autofahrer ihre co2
ersparnis als
emissionszertifikate weiterverkaufen
können für hybride gilt das nicht wo und
wie es das geld geht erklärt isabel de
la vega
rené will hat vor ein paar monaten ein
elektroauto gekauft vom staat gab es
einen zuschuss von 6000 euro und seit
beginn dieses jahres können besitzer
eines e autos zusätzliche sogenannte thg
prämien beantragen thg steht für
treibhausgasminderung ich habe letztes
jahr vor meinem vater erfahren dass es
noch eine thg quote nennt sich das als
zusätzliche prämie gibt für e-autos die
jährlich ausgezahlt wird ja für mich ist
es natürlich eine weitere kleine anreize
und kleine einnahme um halt die das
fahren mit dem elektroauto attraktiver
zu machen die thg prämie von 300 bis 400
euro jährlich kann über dutzende
dienstleister im internet beantragt
werden die grundidee weil ein e auto
hilft die luft zu verbessern wird dem
halter diese treibhausgasminderung
gutgeschrieben er kann die gutschrift an
die mineralölindustrie verkaufen shell
total und co können sie kaufen und auf
ihren treibhausgasausstoß mindernd
anrechnen lassen die branche muss diesen
dringend senken weil sonst
strafzahlungen drohen doch es gibt
kritik an der prämie die der gag wurde
kann dazu führen dass ich mineral und
daneben freikaufen das ist eine senkung
nur für papiere der nur auf dem papier
werden werte gesenkt aber nicht mehr
realität für das klima entscheidend ist
am ende dass mehr menschen aufs
elektroauto umsteigen für halter wäre
nie will ist die prämie immerhin eine
willkommene unterstützung
sri lanka eigentlich ein urlaubsparadies
aber wegen corona kamen in den letzten
zwei jahren kaum noch touristen auch
deshalb steckt die insel im indischen
ozean in einer grossen wirtschaftskrise
dem 22 millionen einwohnern mangelt es
an treibstoff an lebensmitteln an
medikamenten es gibt weiter gewaltsame
unruhen obwohl ministerpräsident
rajapakse zurückgetreten ist denn die
opposition fordert jetzt auch den
rücktritt seines bruders des präsidenten
mehr von normen odenthal
ihr befehl lautet schießen auf plünderer
randalierer brandstifter sri lankas
verteidigungsminister weist seine
soldaten an hart durchzugreifen
und das aufgebot ist massiv
einschüchterung darauf setzt die armee
um bilder wie diese zu verhindern doch
zu groß ist die wut der bürger die
wirtschaftskrise macht aus ihrem leben
einen überlebenskampf jedes vertrauen in
die politik in die elite ist dahin und
auch an der eskalation der gewalt geben
sie der regierung und der armee alle
schuld
sie waren brutal obwohl wir nur für
unsere rechte auf die straße gehen unser
bildungssystem ist kaputt wir haben
nichts zu essen die wirtschaft steht
still die rajapaksa sippel soll
verschwinden
premierminister rajapaksa ist jetzt
zurückgetreten aber so wie er sich
verabschiedet kann man das auch als
drohung verstehen
können vorkommen diese probleme muss man
dann lösen aber niemand darf sich über
die verfassung hinwegsetzen ich habe
nicht den herausforderungen immer
gestellt es ist nicht meine art
davonzulaufen
und sein bruder der staatspräsident ist
weiter im amt macht keine anstalten den
druck nachzugeben
derweil wird der alltag der menschen
immer schwieriger das wenige was es noch
gibt wird teurer und toll
überall nur schlangen jetzt stehen da
diesel schlange wurde morgen stand ich
in der milch überschlagen
staatsbankrott das ist das schwert das
über sri lankas schwebt und die
zündschnur an einem wahren pulverfass
im westjordanland ist eine reporterin
des arabischen fernsehsenders al
dschasira erschossen worden irina boakye
hatte offenbar über einen israelischen
militäreinsatz berichtet als es zu einem
schusswechsel mit militanten
palästinensern kam dabei wurde sie von
einer kugel getroffen beide seiten geben
sich gegenseitig die schuld am tod der
51-jährigen seit märz kommt es in israel
immer wieder zu terroranschlägen als
reaktion führt die israelische armee
fast täglich razzien im besetzten
westjordanland durch
der bekannten kreml-kritiker in maria
alm china ist die flucht aus russland
gelungen obwohl sie unter
polizeiüberwachung stand sie hatte sich
als essens lieferanten verkleidet china
ist sängerin der pop-band pussycat
international bekannt wurde ihre gruppe
von zehn jahren als sie in einer
moskauer kirche gegen präsident putin
protestierte
eigentlich ist der eurovision
songcontest eine unpolitische
veranstaltung doch in kriegszeiten ist
alles anders und so gehört der
ukrainische beitrag jetzt zu den
favoriten bei der ersten halbfinal runde
im italienischen turin nahm das carlos
orchester gestern abend die erste hürde
deutschland als einer der großen
geldgeber der veranstaltung ist bereits
fürs finale am samstag gesetzt und auch
tennis da alexander zverev ist eine
runde weiter er erreichte in rom das
achtelfinale aber der olympiasieger der
hat sich da durchaus schwer getan
bleiben zwei satz sieg gegen den starken
argentinier sebastian bach ist knapp
zwei wochen bleiben zverev noch um den
bestform zu kommen denn dann beginnt das
grand-slam-turnier in paris
ein hart erarbeiteter siegte ihn
trotzdem zufrieden gestellt hat das
möchte ich noch bin ich froh dass ich
das match gewonnen habe weil das hat er
heute wirklich vor allem der erste satz
in beide richtungen gehen können und
dementsprechend haderte alexander zverev
im ersten durchgang mit seiner leistung
konnte sich aber nach holprigen beginn
steigern zum ende des satzes reduzierte
er seine fehlerquote spielte druckvoller
und gewann gegen den flinken argentinien
sebastian preiß mit 8 6 im tie-break
im zweiten satz zu beginn ein ähnliches
bild aber nach einem break zum 5 3
nutzte zverev das eigene aufschlagspiel
und verwandelte seinen ersten matchball
7 zu 6 und 6 3 ein zweisatzerfolg mit
luft nach oben
zum giro d'italia da hat die deutsche
nachwuchshoffnung lennart kemmler einen
tag nach seinem coup auf dem ätna sein
bergtrikot und den zweiten platz in der
gesamtwertung verteidigt um den ersten
platz in der premier league geht das
spannende kopf-an-kopf-rennen weiter
mancity tabellenführer verfolger
liverpool mit jürgen klopp jetzt wieder
punktgleich nach dem 2 1-sieg bei aston
villa
jürgen klopp traut seinen augen schon
nach drei minuten nicht sein torwart
alles und passt vor dem treffer von
glass lewis us thriller führt dort ist
liverpool legende steven gerrard der
coach der sich über sein team aber auch
nicht lange freuen kann sechsten minute
leichtes spiel völliger pool beim
ausgleich durch den ex schalker joel
matip
nur einmal ist der champions league
finalist in der liga diese saison ohne
auswärtstor geblieben hier bei aston
villa werden es zwei usa die homann
erzielt den siegtreffer zum 2 1 in der
65 minute liverpool nimmt drei punkte
mit ist gleichauf mit tabellenführer
manchester city die haben ein spiel
weniger und
die treten heute abend in ufa händen und
das war hier
noch die zahlen vom mittwochslotto sie
lauten 2 24 25 27
28 45 und die superzahl 4 weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto zdf.de
und im zdf text auf seite 5 157
morgen gibt es wieder viel sonne plus
ein bisschen regen im norden wird kühler
als im süden die details hat gleich ist
intelli marietta slomka begrüßt sie um
viertel vor zehn im heute-journal hier
übernimmt morgen jana pareigis alles
gute ihnen einen schönen abend noch und
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
schon glaubte und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter endlich wieder regen im
norden da war es ja die meiste zeit viel
zu trockenen letzter zeit und das hängt
mit dieser kaltfront zusammen die zieht
einmal nach osten und bringt schauer und
gewitter und auch an den alpen gibt es
einige schauer und gewitter aber dass
dann morgen im tagesverlauf in der nacht
gibt es also regen im norden das ganze
zieht allmählich nach osten und hier und
da gibt es auch blitz und donner im
süden klart es auf und die tiefsten
temperaturen die nacht finden wir
richtung nordsee bei neun grad ansonsten
deutlich milder im südwesten bei 16 oder
nach osten 17 grad morgen dann im süden
mit der kaltfront durchaus schauer und
gewitter das zieht an ihr an den alpen
entlang sonst deutlich sonniger nach
osten hin oder im norden in den
westlichen landesteilen sind die wolken
auch mal kompakter die höchsten
temperaturen dazu 15 bis 16 grad im
nordwesten sonst im süden bis 27 grad
hier ist es also deutlich wärmer als im
norden die nächsten tage schauer und
gewitter gibt es durchaus noch an den
alpen und ganz im norden der tröpfelt es
auch 14 bis 25 grad ja samstag lassen
die gewitter allmählich nach und sonntag
wird es deutlich wärmer bis 29 grad ein
schöner abend